you are a very well-known DJ in this  area yeah no no you that's how you  promote yourself  oh yes that's true I say okay who knows  if it is true all right  well you just released a music video and  it's called self-care Sunday correct do  it do you want to say anything about  this video it's wonderful it would teach  you all about how to be nice to your  body and your brains and your torso okay  so this is a video a music video that  you put together called self-care Sunday  we're gonna show a clip right now oh I  love that okay let's take a look okay  [Music]  okay  [Music]  oh no that guy is that your trainer yes  he's dead he died he died what happened  trying too hard Conan I love this man  check out fluids new music video  self-care Sunday on Team Coco's YouTube  channel and very sorry that you lost  your trainer  I'm very sad as well not really you  don't seem to be